nos acompaña a rigoberto herrera es
portavoz del departamento forestal y de
protección contra incendios de
california señor herrera muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24
preguntarle en primer lugar si hay
factores que hacen de esta región un
escenario más susceptible o propenso a
este tipo de conflagraciones
sí buenos días si estamos anticipando
ahorita unos vientos que vengan y van a
ser eróticos que vienen en diferentes
direcciones estamos aquí participando
que los vientos lleguen hasta las 65
millas por hora que viene siendo muy
peligroso porque puede causar el
incendio crezca mucho más rápido que lo
que estamos anticipando pero todavía
tenemos refuerzos tratando de llegar a
las áreas o poner refuerzos en frente de
esas áreas donde tengamos probablemente
hay algún problema claro sí si las
condiciones climáticas claramente no
están ayudando ha hablado usted de
refuerzo california pidió ayuda a otros
estados del país y también pidió su
internacional a canadá australia son
insuficientes los recursos del estado
para hacer frente a esta situación sí
pues con eso estamos batallando más o
menos 27 incendios
en todo el estado todos los recursos que
tenemos están batallando los incendios
está causando que cuando pidamos más
refuerzos no puedan ser mandados o si
los recibimos tardan en llegar que causa
que el incendio crezca también con eso
el humo y la el clima los aires no está
documentando no está ayudando para que
las avionetas ni los helicópteros puedan
volar y también los las avionetas y los
helicópteros no pueden volar cuando hay
mucho humo en el aire está causando que
no podamos mandar los recursos a unas
áreas porque es muy peligroso y a veces
ocupamos que esos avionetas con
helicópteros
ayuden a los refuerzos en el piso